in this capsule we will see
the algorithm the c3 so we saw up
now that it was possible
to incorporate heuristics sound
general in the bach algorithm
tracking search on has three types of
risks and we have heuristics
sure were commenting on what we choose
next barrier it was the method
varna signed desert on comment this
we choose and how are we
actually orders the values ​​signed for
the variable chooses so that was the
orderly value method in our local
and we saw a difference algorithm
that is to say the flu that allows
detect the assignments that are
conflictual and detect them in advance
and which also helps to reduce
domains of variants assigned for
speed up the search
so what we want to see is actually
another inference algorithm that is going
to be a little more powerful so
the algorithm fore-checking they work
still pretty well it's pretty
simple is what we saw what they
propagate information about
constraints between variables signed
to variables that are not yet at
sign however it does not detect if there
is not currently conflict that we are going
create local conflicts between
variables are not yet to sign that's
to say that every time we check is
what it detects a conflict between a
unassigned variable is a variable a
signed but not between the non variables
assigned germany we have an example here
imagine that we do the research bac
jacking either one is here in our
note research and we have these areas there
that have been updated with
the jacking algorithm so currently
for rich who does not tell us to stop
research however we notice if we
consider the pair of variables nts a
so we have their domain justice had
between who is here and who are
variants correspond to states that
share a border right here so
they must not take the same value
however in their field we see that
the only values ​​that both
variables
it's exactly the same value
ie blue so at that moment it's
in fact we could have stopped
search right now because we know
will never understand solve this problem
there by making other assignments of
variables of values ​​and in what we
will see if an inference algorithm that
will spread information about
constraints between non variables
assigned and that will allow precisely
to check locally 6th not
conflicts between variables that have no
still been assigned and so that's
the algorithm to 6 3 6 that will do if
was going to be we'll see in this
capsule then the ac3 algorithm is a
algorithm that of horgues thus consists
so this is a type one way to do
the propagation constraints that is
rather simple the idea is to check
compatibility between arches that's at
say constraint relationships between
pardon the compatibility of contracts
between two variables
so I'm going to define what I want
say by an arc that is compatible
so if we have an arc x green y os x and y
are variables going to say he's
arc compatible anyone who is
inconsistent if and only if for
each x value of the variable grown
there is at least one permitted value of
9 to allow y for the large variable y
so that's the definition of an arc
which is compatible and in a slang
recoil rate system so what are we going
to do with it is that every time
we will make assignments
we will change the areas of
variables to make sure that all
against all the bows forgive all the
arcs between two variables are combative
so for all the variables we have
signed we will take all the arches
so that means that are constrained
as here in wa and mt
we will make sure that the bow of w
varieties and ntv w is compatible for
do that for all the constraints
and specifically all of
father of variables that share a
constraint then an example here of an arc
of the variable s is the variable nsw
and the question is to know is this
that the arc in question is compatible
in that if it is compatible why
for the only possible value of rsa that
is blue in fact we have a variable so
this is the hic rexie pardon a value that
correspond yz ci and who red in this
case that allows to assign is saab
so in other words it's gone
for me to assign blue saha
since I could have assigned nsw to red
so because of that it's tahar kessi
sisters veronique double life is
compatible I'm going to take off a bit of
clear let's look at another our bow so
in that if the act of nsw would see his
dance only if there are not compatible
why because there is there is a
value x small ex so seven years that if
it's the blue value for the variable
nsw which is such that there is none
no value of the variable is what
allows to satisfy the constraint so
it's not possible for me to assinie
nsw to blue and then assign n is not to
one of its possible values
the only possible value these blues then
i can not see blue nsw and is healthy and
blue so arched not compatible then
what i'm doing in the ac3 algorithm
know that I'm going to change the domain of
nsw for the art to become competitive
the way to do it is simply
remove blues from his domain from his
permissible value area
so if I do that because if the
just and the unfair red in like
possible value of nsw and if I sign
nsw a red to assign is blue and
I will satisfy the constraint between
two so the arched made compatible
and I will continue like that they field
on all possible arcs
variables not yet so remark
however that before when I made the
comparison
ah yeah when i checked hes bow
so varane swg suppose the domain
dns double nsw contained red and blue
because I just updated so
to reduce the domain dns double life
it's more the know w his domain
that we just hold red then
in the moss and troy booth I'm going
having to make sure to reconsider this art
closed to them check because the
domain of the variable sw laval towards
which the bow points to change because
that if we are lucky by changing the
field of sw ans in the blue green a
do we still have that arc of s over nsw
is valid since red has stayed in
the domain so that allows me to assign
sandy by assigning nsw to left this
means that the art that is still
competitive so the algorithm sit down
would continue to adhere on all
possible arcs suppose liberation
next two years and three we come to
this target arc in this case also the
change in the domain we would do that
would be to remove red since I can
not to sign red vea because a
mind can only be assigned to
you because if we had a
incompatibility then I'm going to remove
red of the domain of the variable v by
against I can keep green and blue
since we reported this w to red
painted and signed vea to bhl and
I'll continue like that so let's suppose
that I now consider the arc of s to
vanves mt in that if I observe that
I can not sign her anymore since
there is no value dente that allows me
to assign sandy the game should
remove from his field the blue value
is there the ac3 algorithm would detect that
I have a domain that quickly makes it so
I detected a conflict and so my
algae of inference will return this
information-there will return a ball a
which means that you're going to say that a
conflict that will happen
possibly that is impossible to
solve and so search for baxter
king sturge to stop there and back off
towards for example considering a
new assignment of my variable here
the sni rather than the age signare
could sign it to blue at red darcos
so here's a slightly more formal way
how does the algorithm work at these
three broke it's for arkoon
small right system is because
exist different versions so we
is going to look at ac3 version then this
that we do in rites to these three
years starts by building a queue of
all possible arches between pairs
of variables that share a complete
so I have to simplify if I have
assumed that there is an arc function of the
csp who takes my explain us
return all the all the arcs between
but then sand variable I'm going
interests on actually I'm not going
only iterate on the arc queue but
I'm going ethereal until until
what phil acts become fast so
time so long that philippe is
not empty
I will continue interest on what
is contained by that he is at each
iteration what I do is that I
take the first bow file element
so in this case too an arc was
offered my first variable xxi which
point to the variable mj in my
childhood ixic j it means that I have a
arc xy
around 6 am I'm disappointed I'll call the
revised function for xy is required in
also specifying the configuration of
mons and inspire so it's the same
function revise that we had seen in a
previous capsule is it going to do
this is precisely what is described before
know I'll check for all
values ​​of xxi è what exists a
angie value that allows me to
satisfy me constrained if it's not
the case I remove this value from
eksi domain the time I return
information know what I changed
the domain of eksi and I return the
new csp with domains
possibly updated if domenech
if we changed and there as I had
said beforehand I start with who is
what the xxi domain renders empty a
little like in falling we do the same
something so obvious because if I
returns wrong said I return
information know that there is a
conflict that is detected and what will
to do that bach tracking be I see
do a jacques bac have to go back
on the other hand if the domain is not yet
empty what am I going to do in ac3 so
a fore-checking I will continue in
improve nothing else to do by the
continuation in consists here consists of six
pardon to c3 for all
variables etc score who are neighbors
of xxi so the set of variables that
share a constraint with xxi for the
we remember well here it's a
variable for which the domain has
changed six ex quo is a variable that
is different from the variable etc if
for which I have just made sure that
arctic sea and j and k
build but become compatible for
other variables that share a
constraint with etc if i'm going to add
a bow
I add an act x as to xy
so adding the pair will educate
Exquisite in my dark phil in this movie
so I'm going to double-check the bow two ex
kovarik ci because ex body because
the domain of xi has changed so that's
possible that now is late
the dx kovac ci is no longer compatible
and that I have to reduce once again
the domain of xk and that's a
iteration of the c3 and I continue as
that until the arc arch wire is
made fast ie all the
all the arches we are now
compatible
after reducing the areas of maize
variable or the grid to stop if
I detect a conflict ie if the
domain of one for one of the arcs and xi
and xiie if the xxi domain has become
empty in this case I would go wrong
then if not I would go back
cabbage but I had managed to move on to
through everything but bow and that was
become compatible I will return with the
new csp with the domains that have
been simplified so that's
the algorithm the pseudo that the algorithm
ac3 some notes on the algorithm in
so what can we do with
the war is enough 3 that's either the most
just once at the very beginning so that
may be worth calling the
grimace and three at the very beginning of
the execution where we can do a little
as a game we have written in the pure of
bach jacking search code call it
after each new assignment
of time to a variable so it's in
did what recommended the tooth
the algorithm is the pseudo conne that
I specified in the capsules
former
but we could also rain at
early kingson bakker who before
even to have done any even before
to have made a summons of a
variable value in terms of its
complexity its complexity is going to be of in
top of his times halls to 3 or
stop the number of constraints and
it's the size of the domains so
maybe a quick little explanation
why do we get this to revise well
his teeth high halls 2
why because for each element
of the variable domain etc if I have to
do a check to know is this
that I find a bar and a value there
the variable grant y that allows me to
satisfy one on one for that I have
so find a value y that is
compatible with an x ​​value for my
other variable and so I have to
perish for every value of x i
must is terrible for every value of
there
so I have two loops on elements
so that gives me a complexity at dd at
square provides support what must
revise his apps by in c3 in these
three games must alter on the arches
we raised arch and so that's the number
of arh that can be reinserted or
times why at times but because
whenever a certain art is
that we removed one or more one or more
value of the variable of the first
variable in my bow since
values ​​in the domain of a variable
but I can not insert it more than high
de faith so that means that the number
of reintegration in all these times
opus 5 complexity oc times d and
since the complexity of revising so
it's the number of times I can
call revised then the complexity of
revise cod squared I get a
overall complexity of
it's times oca times would have so
cdo liver that so that's the
complexity from 2 to 6 3 there is a
error version in the hull father and to
cdo square it's called ac 4 but it's
finds that his three is on average
more efficient so if you want more
information I invite you to watch
the literature on this subject there and
I add and I would add to finish
which sense to look at my section 6.3 of
book kings are upset that you
go see that yo some problems of
satisfaction of constraints or we have a
particular structure on the
constraints that is possible to exploit
so some serious constraint by
a structure 5 like a tree and that's
possible to exclude from exploiting the
simplicity of the structure to have
improvements that are sometimes
exponential so improve the time of
exponentially computes it for this type
problem there is something that we
will take a stake in the capsules here
but you can learn more at
see section 6.5 of the book of
return of the nordiques